pour s'évader on peut aussi haut niveau
au niveau mental
on est tous conscients que le football
ligne et tout ce qui est au niveau
social surtout au niveau culture et quel
regard portez-vous sur toutes ces années
à monaco à la juventus en équipe de
france
le football le football c'est ma vie et
le football m'a beaucoup donné en temps
dans tous les contextes et quand on a la
chance de revenir en étant ambassadeur
voir les gens
nous reconnaître les choses qu'on a fait
et non surtout au niveau du beau
football et ça c'est touchant
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 1er juin
nikol pashinian visite à paris avant
russell demain le premier ministre
arménien par intérim reçue à l'elysée
par emmanuel macron au coeur des
discussions le conflit qui oppose
l'arménie à l'azerbaïdjan le chef de
l'état français a réaffirmé son soutien
à erevan à la france et l'allemagne
attendent des explications de la part
des états unis et du danemark à un
consortium de médias européens révélé
hier que la haine et celle agences de
renseignement américaines avaient
espionné plusieurs cadres européens dont
la chancelière allemande angela merkel
avec l'éventuel complicité de copenhague
une affaire qui n'est pas sans rappeler
le programme de surveillance illégale
révélée par edward sont des noms en 2013
un homme d'origine algérienne soupçonné
d'être l'auteur d' insultes racistes
contre un livreur noir a été arrêté et
placé en garde à vue
les faits se sont déroulés dimanche soir
à cergy dans le val d'oise une enquête
avait été ouverte notamment pour
apologie de l' esclavage après la
diffusion sur les réseaux sociaux de la
vidéo de l'agression très violente
le racisme entre les différentes
communautés d'origine étrangère s à un
sujet tabou en france comment
l'expliquer ce sera l'objet de notre
décryptage
[Musique]
c'est une visite de travail de deux
jours à bruxelles demain le premier
ministre arménien par intérim et donc à
paris aujourd'hui
nikol pashinian reçu à l'elysée par
emmanuel macron pour évoquer le conflit
qui persiste entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan
pour plus de précisions nous retrouvons
tout de suite david kelly fa bonsoir
david
rencontre donc attendu que peut-on
retenir de cet échange entre nicole
pashinian et emmanuel macron
j écoutais nikol pashinian le premier
ministre arménien par intérim est arrivé
vers 13h15 pour un déjeuner de travail
avec emmanuel macron après avoir
rencontré le président de l'assemblée
nationale richard ferrand ce matin est
le but de cette visite de cette visite
avait clamé un appui politique ensuite
au regain de tension avec l'azerbaïdjan
lors de leur déclaration conjointe à la
presse avant cette rencontre emmanuel
macron a rappelé à son soutien réaffirmé
son soutien au peuple arménien nikol
pashinian lui a été reconnaissant pour
toute l'aide apportée par la france que
ce soit sur le plan politique mais aussi
sur le plan humanitaire et économique
écoutez si le cessez le feu est
globalement respecté au haut karabagh
beaucoup reste à faire et la france est
prête à poursuivre son soutien au profit
des populations
je pense à la nécessaire libération de
tous les prisonniers
il s'agit des prisonniers de guerre
comme des autres détenus à la levée des
restrictions d'accès aux organisations
internationales humanitaires et aux
graves problèmes des zones minées les
troupes azerbaïdjanaise doivent quitter
le territoire souverain de l'arménie
j'appelle donc clairement les parties à
revenir alors position du 11 mai sommes
solidaires de l'arménie et nous le
resterons
et en ces temps d'épreuve la france est
déterminée à ce que la paix revienne
enfin dans la région française la france
et l'arménie ont des relations
privilégiées et il est très important de
souligner que dans ce contexte le peuple
arménien la république d'arménie a
toujours ont toujours ressentie ont
toujours apprécié la lampe pour le
soutien de la france en particulier
celui du président macron la france et
en particulier le président macron
continuer ce soutien et s'éteint et cela
est
essentiel pour notre région et pour
surmonter toutes les crises et les
tensions qui ont lieu dans notre région
même vous l'avez entendu dans les mots
du chef d'état français est une nouvelle
fois il a une nouvelle fois insisté
assure le fait sur la nécessité de
retirer immédiatement les troupes
azerbaijan du territoire arménien à
nikol pashinian pashinian lui accuse
bakou d'avoir violé la frontière
arménienne au pouvoir depuis 2000 18 il
est dans une situation délicate dans son
pays considérés comme responsables de la
défaite militaire dans le haut karabakh
est vécue comme une véritable
humiliation nationale pour la plupart
des arméniens et l'opposition politique
il a dû a déposé sa démission en avril
elle sera effective à partir du 20 juin
prochain date des élections législatives
anticipées malgré le cessez le feu signé
sous l'égide de moscou est là le
déploiement de soldats russes de la paix
les tensions restent vives dans cette
région est précisément des tensions qui
laisse craindre un nouveau conflit
meurtrier cette visite était une manière
pour emmanuel macron de ne joue un rôle
mais de médiateur car l'arménie lui
avait reproché justement son silence
lors du conflit en novembre dernier
david
exactement à stéphanie puisque vous
l'avez dit emmanuel macron avait été
accusé d'avoir été silencieux alors de
ce conflit l'objectif était de trouver
une issue diplomatique car la pression
est toujours intense dans cette région
en témoigne l des incidents récurrents à
ces dernières semaines la semaine
dernière six soldats arméniens ont été
blessés par les troupes de bakou et
l'azerbaïdjan l'azerbaïdjan a dénoncé de
son côté des tirs arméniens ayant fait
des blessés également des prisonniers à
des soldats ont été faits prisonniers
par les troupes de bakou
emmanuel ma point d'ailleurs insisté sur
la libération de tous les prisonniers
sur la levée des restrictions d'accès
aux organisations internationales
humanitaires la preière a également été
au coeur des discussions cet après midi
bien évidemment pour nikol pashinian la
suite ça se passera à bruxelles dès
demain pour cette dure tournée
diplomatique où on l'aura compris un
l'objectif est de trouver à des appuis
européen dans ce récent contexte de
regain de tension avec l'azerbaïdjan
merci d'éviter les femmes en direct de
l'elysée et pour approfondir le sujet
parler de cette visite nous sommes avec
patricia lalonde vice présidente du
groupe de réflexion géo pragma
chercheuse ellipses
bonsoir madame
c'est d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france donc un ministre par intérim que
reçoit aujourd'hui emmanuel macron le
rappel l'accord signé sous l'égide de la
russie
il y a plusieurs mois à laquelle la
france n'a pas eu son mot à dire
on peut s'interroger sur cette porte est
aujourd'hui de 7 heures rencontre entre
les deux dirigeants
eh bien écoutez oui c'était c'est assez
étonnant mais en même en même temps il
faut il faut savoir que comme monsieur
pashinian du temps est en campagne
électorale
actuellement puisqu'il a démissionné il
a démissionné pour essayer de se faire
réélire à nouveau aux élections lors de
ces élections le 20 juin
monsieur pas chignon cherche trois shows
du ca il est venu en france
évidemment pour chercher l'appui de la
france pour des raisons à la fois
économiques culturelles et ça a été dit
dans votre votre reportage évidemment
pour étayer d'organiser le retour des
réfugiés des prisonniers de guerre qui
sont nombreux qui pose dès qu'il pose un
vrai problème dans les négociations il
est là également on pour faire
contrepoids à l'influencé russe puisque
l'opposition à nikol pashinian lui
reproche beaucoup d'avoir pratiquement
tous et des eaux russes enfin en tout
cas d'avoir cédé trop une trop grande
proportion des territoires aux
azerbaïdjanais est bon donc
il a besoin de se refaire je dirais une
virginité par rapport à contrepoids à
vrai contrepoids par rapport à l'
influence russe
et puis troisièmement à cause de ces
regains de tension qui ont lieu comme ça
a été expliqué également dans votre
reportage
parce que ces tensions sont tout à fait
inquiétant il ya quand même six
arméniens qui ont été kidnappés par par
les azerbaïdjanaises l'ecal
d'azerbaïdjan a dit non non c'est pas
vrai enfin les les deux camps les deux
camps se renvoient la balle
pour les la russie a donné l'impression
de pas trop ne pas trop vouloir se
mouiller bon visiblement ils ont quand
même envoyé le fsb a quand même
finalement envoyé des troupes sur place
donc si vous voulez c'est quand même
très inquiétant parce que tout le monde
a eu très peur lors de l'ordre du
conflit à propos du haut karabakh et
maintenant on est à nouveau dans une
tension très forte
à propos de frontières qui ne sont pas
très claires qui ne sont pas très bien
défini tout ça est flou donc je pense
que c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles pour lesquels pashinian nikol
pashinian via faire sa tournée auprès du
président macron et auprès des européens
et c'est vrai et c'est vrai que la
france a des très bonnes relations avec
l'azerbaïdjan et avait toujours depuis
toujours de très bonnes relations avec
avec l'arménie est donc et c'est vrai
que la france a été très silencieuse
pendant ce conflit parce que silencieux
parce que lille était il était vraiment
dans les grains à pied dans peut-être à
pied dans un dans chaque camp
alors là 1er juin qui dit qu'elle fera
tout pour je cite obtenir la désescalade
et le rétablissement du dialogue entre
bakou et erevan dans les faits
concrètement que va faire emmanuel
macron parce que encore une fois la
france pas fait grand chose par la force
des choses quand il ya eu ce conflit
qu'est ce qu'elle peut faire maintenant
pour rétablir ce dialogue et à l'écouté
très franchement je ne crois pas qu'elle
puisse vraiment faire grand chose
actuellement je pense que c'est ce sont
les russes qui est un petit peu le tir a
peu qui tire les ficelles et qu'ils ont
et qu'ils sont eux qui sont dans le jeu
dans le jeu franchement je ne sais tu as
c'est assez compliqué et alors ce que
peut faire ce que peut faire la france
c'est les troupes
ils ont demandé le retour des troupes de
l'ouest chez eux l'organisation de
sécurité et de coopération européenne et
donc c'est un appel que nikol pashinian
faire la bce donc ils vont demander que
les troupes à nouveau que les troupes
viennent viennent sur le terrain pour
saper reposer donc
ça c'est une des choses effectivement qu
emmanuel macron enfin que la france peut
pousser la france et l'europe doivent
pousser pour leur aide humanitaire
l'implication française qui veut
contribuer sur le plan humanitaire avec
cette aide exceptionnelle accordée par
paris au comité international de la
croix rouge
c'est suffisant écouter de toute façon
c'est c'est toujours très important
d'apporter de l'aide humanitaire donc ça
on peut rien dire mais je non je ne
pense pas que ce sera suffisant il va
falloir quelque chose de plus politique
obligatoirement merci un bébé encore une
fois on oui je vous en prie le jour où
l'assemblée encore une fois je dis on en
revient au rôle au rôle des russes qui
qui qui joue un jeu très très très malin
dans toute cette affaire en s'appliquant
pas trop en laissant bon mais voilà mais
je pensais aux limicoles pas chez nous
il ya fait signer cet accord de paix
tout de même on le rappelle alors qu'il
y avait un conflit meurtrier sur le
terrain c'est un conflit qu'il faut
rappeler que c'est un conflit qui a fait
6000 membres
c'est quand même c'est quand même énorme
et c'est vrai que l'ailé mais les rues
sont en fait on organisait si je puis
dire le cessez le feu et je crois que on
a beaucoup reproché à nikol pashinian
d'avoir accepté 5 puisque puisque les
arméniens ou perdu quelques glacis de
territoire autour de du haut karabakh et
ils ont perdu la ville de souche à de
choucha donc c'était quand même ce
qu'ils avaient quand même un revers si
je puis dire pour les arméniens et comme
la france ne disait rien à l'époque
n'est pas intervenu n'a rien dit bon
voilà les side on est parti dans une
espèce de 2,2 comme on dit on va essayer
de remettre ça sur la table à nouveau
merci en tout cas patricia lalonde vice
président du groupe de réflexion j'ai
oprag machinchose ellipses est de nous
avoir apporté votre analyse sur cette
rencontre aujourd'hui merci à vous
ils exigent la clarté complète emmanuel
macron et angela merkel appelle les
états unis et le danemark à s'expliquer
l' agence de renseignement américaine
est accusée d'avoir utilisé
l'infrastructure danoise afin
d'espionner de hauts responsables
européens dont la chancelière allemande
est détaillé avec yamina benhaida
cessionnaire entre amis n'est pas
acceptable ce sont les mots employés par
angela merkel en réaction aux possibles
pratiques d'espionnage des services de
renseignement américains l'année c'est
avec l'aide du danemark la télévision
publique danoise révèle dans son enquête
que la haine et cei aurait espionné
plusieurs hauts responsables européens
via des câbles sous marins depuis le
danemark
parmi les personnalités espionnées un
nom ressort celui de la chancelière
allemande angela merkel qui a vite réagi
j'ai été rassuré par le fait que le
danemark le gouvernement danois
le ministre de la défense a également
dit très clairement ce qu'il pense de
ces questions et à cet égard je vois une
bonne base non seulement pour clarifier
les faits mais aussi pour établir des
relations de confiance en plein conseil
des ministres franco allemand emmanuel
macron lieu aussi s'est exprimé le
président français dont le pays aurait
également été espionnée par la haine et
c'est tout comme la chancelière
allemande
il attend des explications ce n'est pas
acceptable entre alliés de manière très
claire
ça l'est encore moins entre alliés et
partenaires européens et donc je suis
attaché au lien de confiance qui
unissent européens et américains il n'y
a pas de place entre nous pour le
soupçon c'est pourquoi ce que nous
attendons c'est la clarté complète
nous avons demandé à ce que nos
partenaires danoise américain apporte
toutes les informations sur ces
révélations et sur ces faits passés et
surtout apporter toute la clarté sur les
pratiques présente
angela merkel mais aussi le ministre
allemand des affaires étrangères de
l'époque frank walter steinmeier et le
chef de l'opposition d'alors peer
steinbrück figurent parmi les personnes
espionnées par la nsf
selon le média public danemark radio
lagence de renseignement a ainsi pu
accéder à leurs sms appels téléphoniques
et échangent via
net y compris les recherches le chat et
les services de messagerie toujours
selon la télévision publique danoise
cette révélation pourrait entamer la
confiance entre le danemark et l'europe
ne fait que et je cite encore la
chancelière merkel qui a eu de
l'espionnage entre amis entre
partenaires c'est la déclaration la plus
dure que merkel est fait depuis et 2013
et surtout ce que je pense être le plus
déplorable dans tout cela c'est que
cette pratique a très probablement prise
une forme plus sophistiqués l'opération
dunham heures c'est le nom de code de
l'enquète a été déposée sur le bureau de
la direction de la danemark radio en mai
moins de deux ans après les premières
révélations du lanceur d'alert eduardo
del actuellement exilé en russie
il appelle copenhague et washington à
une transparence complète sur le dossier
après cette demande d'explication de la
part de la france et de l'allemagne
quelles sont les réactions pour plus de
précision on retrouve en tout de suite
notre reporter thomas bonnet en direct
de washington bonsoir tomar 48 heures
après les révélations de la presse
européenne sur cette complicité danoise
lors d' écoute de dirigeants européens
toujours aucune réaction de la maison
blanche
donc c'est silence radio après la
parution de ces informations et ce
malgré les demandes d'explication lancé
par la france et l'allemagne alors joe
biden était concentrée ce lundi sur le
jour férié ici aux etats unis le
memorial day est aujourd'hui en
déplacement à tulsa dans l'oklahoma et
puis de son côté le chef de la
diplomatie anthony blinken est en
déplacement au costa rica alors ces
accusations quand même été relayée par
la presse américaine on y découvre
notamment que la haine et ça ne souhaite
pas donner suite aux demandes
d'interview qui ont été formulées par ce
par la presse américaine il a toutefois
des experts selon des anciens des
services de renseignements qui sont
interrogés dans ses articles et minimise
un peu en expliquant que c'est tout à
fait normal à d'espionner ses amis on
peut se demander pourquoi coredi ces
experts si ces accusations avaient été
deux
de la russie ou de la chine par exemple
en tout cas cette affaire est
embarrassante pour joe biden qui on le
rappelle était vice président au moment
des faits en 2013 lors des premières
révélations faites par edouard snowdon
barack obama avait déjà dû répondre aux
interrogations voire aux accusations il
faut se souvenir qu'à l'époque
angela merkel avait appelé directement
le locataire de la maison blanche barack
obama à l'époque pour lui demander des
explications
alors quelles conséquences en a pour les
relations entre l'union européenne et
des états unis
c'est justement ce qu'on va pouvoir
mesurer ces prochains jours alors pour
le moment malgré les condamnations on
reste sur une ligne plutôt molle du côté
des pays européens et n'a pas vu par
exemple de menaces de sanctions et puis
surtout donc ces révélations
interviennent à quelques jours d'un
déplacement très important pour joe
biden qui va se rendre en europe il y
aura le sommet de l'otan au sommet du g7
et un sommet justement entre l'union
européenne et les etats unis
on verra à ce moment là quelle sera
l'attitude de baden s'il ya des excuses
par exemple et puis on verra aussi si la
confiance a été quelque peu entamé alors
parmi les sujets qui seront abordés lors
de ce voyage
mais justement des négociations sur un
accord concernant le transfert des
données transatlantique qui va remplacer
un accord précédent qui avait été
invalidée par l'union européenne en
raison d'inquiétudes concernant des
activités d'espionnage américain on est
déjà en plein coeur du sujet dans les
pays membres de l'union européenne répit
temps assez régulièrement leur volonté
de souveraineté bien ils ont là une
occasion de montrer concrètement au
président américain
la politique qu'il souhaite avoir merci
thomas bonnin en direct de washington
nfr d'espionnage qui fait réagir la
russie la correspondance à moscou de
veyrac d'hoffmann
la vérité est beaucoup plus effrayante
que ces informations isolé qui
apparaissent actuellement dans les
médias a déclaré la porte parole de la
diplomatie russe mariya zakharova en
commentant l affaire d'espionnage des
dirigeants européens par là et nsa pour
la diplomate russe les européens n'ont
aucune idée de ce qui se passe dans leur
monde
je vous propose d'écouter pyrénées
l'échangé l'impression que pour ce qui
est des règles c'est peut-être leur
nouvelle règle
de ne pas les appliquer à eux mêmes je
n'y a de gagner sa place
c'est une façon de montrer qu'ils ne
sont pas concernés et cette position est
même plus générale les etats unis se
sont exclus de tout cadre juridique pour
se poser un superviseur de tout le monde
c'est une position qu'ils prennent
depuis des années mais spéciaux maire ya
deux ans
j'estime que ce n'est que la partie
émergée de l'iceberg est en réalité la
situation pour les pays membres de
l'otan est bien plus grave que celle
dont tout le monde vient de prendre
connaissance
celle-ci même que l'otan le secrétaire
général de l'otan les dirigeants de
l'union européenne et d'autres évitent
d'aborder sa hyundai maria zakharova a
également pointé du doigt que ce n'était
pas pour la première fois que les
chancelleries européennes ne réagisse
quasiment pas aux informations
concernant l'espionnage par la nsa les
récentes révélations sont le dernier
épisode de la série de scandales des
écoutes opérées par les services
américains sur leurs alliés mais
l'indignation reste une simple posture
dans le reste de l'actualité joe biden
attendu pour réparation le président
américain se rend à tulsa comme nous
l'expliquait thomas bonnet il ya
quelques instants en oklahoma pour
commémorer les 100 temps d'un des pires
massacres de l'histoire des états unis
il ya un siècle plus de 300 afro
américains venus protester contre
l'arrestation d'un des leurs accusé
d'avoir agressé une femme blanche ont
été tuées par des manifestants blanc le
quartier greenwood à tulsa connu sous le
nom de black wall street avait alors été
incendié et pillé une veillette est
organisée à lundi soir vous savez il
devrait y avoir des excuses publiques
envers les gens pour ça et vous savez
que ça manque
ça a été enterré ça vient juste d'être
mise en lumière pour beaucoup beaucoup
de gens même des gens qui sont nés à
tout ça il ne le savais pas jusqu'à
récemment et j'espère que ce pays
s'occupera enfin des citoyens qui l'a
maltraité pendant des siècles à savoir
les afro américains
ça sera quelque chose que je pourrais
vraiment partager avec ma famille et
tous mes petits neveux et nièces et les
aider à comprendre qu'il faut connaître
son histoire
ce soir le chef du gouvernement libyen
est à paris et rémy de beida poursuit sa
tournée il s'entretient avec emmanuel
macron dans la soirée au menu des
discussions notamment le processus de
stabilisation de la libye le premier
ministre libyen qui depuis samedi s'est
rendu à alger et à rome françois xavier
lambert c'est au son des hymnes de leurs
deux pays que mario draghi et abdelhamid
beiba arrive dans la cour du palais
djigui le siège de la présidence du
conseil italien pour leur deuxième
rencontre plusieurs dossiers sont au
coeur des discussions la reconstruction
libyenne
le renforcement de la collaboration
économique entre tripoli et rome
mais surtout la question migratoire un
dossier sensible qui préoccupe toutes
les puissances européennes
les deux dirigeants se sont engagés à
agir de manière coordonnée pour mieux
réguler les flux de migrants
je pense qu'il s'agit d'un devoir moral
et que c'est aussi dans l'intérêt de la
libye d'assurer le plein respect des
droits des réfugiés et des migrants tout
cela n'est pas seulement une
responsabilité libyenne maltaise ou
italienne c'est une responsabilité
commune après rome le premier ministre
libyen va poursuivre sa tournée en
europe
il sera reçu aujourd'hui par emmanuel
macron le président français fortement
impliqué dans le processus de
stabilisation de la libye
en mars dernier il avait reçu le chef du
conseil présidentiel libyen
l'occasion pour la france d'afficher son
soutien à ce nouvel exécutif de
transition et de consolider sa présence
dans la région
je voulais ici leur témoigner de tout
mon soutien celui de la france aux
autorités
bienne nouvelle unifiée issus du
processus de transition politique que la
france appelle de ses voeux depuis
plusieurs années auxquels nous avons
activement contribué le président
français a également insisté à plusieurs
reprises sur le retrait des puissances
étrangères présentes en libye selon
l'onu 20 mille mercenaires de tous
horizons seraient présents dans le pays
parmi eux plusieurs centaines de
militaires turcs y déployait dans le
cadre d'accords conclus avec le
précédent exécutif de tripoli les défis
sont donc nombreux pour l'actuel
gouvernement libyen qui va tenter de
poursuivre le processus de stabilisation
du pays
objectif majeur organisé des élections
législatives et présidentielle à la fin
de l'année restez avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons de
l'agression raciste d'un livreur de
repas cergy dimanche dernier un homme a
été interpellé dans la journée et placé
en garde à vue à paris
et puis direction l'assemblée nationale
qui examine la loi terrorisme de
nouvelles mesures pour encadrer la
sortie de prison des condamnés ont été
proposés
[Musique]
le président français avait annoncé
vouloir créer un commandement militaire
de l'espace l'espace est devenu
complètement clé en termes à la fois
militaire et en termes économiques
l'espace et est devenu un lieu de
confrontation potentiel je pense que
militarisation ça veut dire que
finalement il ya un risque pour assister
à une guerre dans les oui la guerre est
possible il ya de multiples façons
d'amener de rendre inopérant
effectivement des satellites
l'espace est encore un lieu pacifique
mais n'est plus que ça il peut devenir
effectivement un espace de confrontation
dans lequel des nations ou des groupes
peuvent intervenir pour détruire et et
causé des dommages considérables
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petit coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la veille d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient des guignols
aujourd'hui une gauche extrêmement
d'user de tous les moyens de notre
époque sont dans la grande interview on
vit tous les jours sans faire attention
que tout en dépend c'est l'unité de
mesure de toute chose une convention
admise par tous s'il arrive quelque
chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
si demain d'un conflit ouvert ce produit
entre la chine et les usa
on peut penser il se déroulera dans la
mer de chine du sud
car cette zone est totalement
stratégique pour les deux ans en 2019
la chine a construit en une année ce
sont plus de bâtiments que les états
unis en quatre ans guerre de 1941 à 1945
en affichant ainsi sa souveraineté en
mer de chine du sud
pékin fait prévaloir des droits
historiques sur les règles
internationales dont une puissance
dominante constate qu'elle est en train
de se faire dépasser par une puissance
émergente la tentation normale et de la
détruire au plan politique ou militaire
avant qu'elle n'arrive à 6 fin
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle les gens qui
font appel à moi s'engage dans un combat
c'est parce que il ya de l'autre côté
une classe ultra privilégiés qui est
prête à sacrifier l'être humain en
réalité pour accroître encore davantage
ses richesses
les chiffres qui sont avancés qui sont
montrés aux salariés et à leurs
représentants sont des chiffres en
décalage parfois vertigineux avec les
chiffres que l'on trouve dans la
comptabilité officielle notre travail
c'est justement de dissiper cet écran de
fumée de gratter le maquillage et de
faire émerger la réalité des profits
gigantesques que réalise et fiable mais
comment peuvent ils mentir comme des
arracheurs de dents à ce point
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coût politique a jamais été obligé
de dire la veille d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent en soi vient des
lignes aujourd'hui on a une gauche
extrême musée tous les témoins de notre
époque sont dans la grande interwiew
[Musique]
à 20h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez une enquête ouverte
à cergy et un suspect interpellé ce
mardi suite à l'agression d'un livreur
et des injures racistes
les faits ont eu lieu devant un
restaurant de cette ville du val d'oise
et en susciter l'indignation le récit
est signée valentin carpentier
ils sont venus en nombre devant le
restaurant brasco de cergy à l'appel de
la brigade anti négrophobie
plus de 150 personnes rassemblées en
soutien aux livreurs agressé devant
l'établissement dimanche soir venu
récupérer une commande vers 22h30
l'homme est agressé par un autre
individu voilà il a traité il a traité
d'esclaves
il a fait saigner voilà sont soit tu
pars faire là parce que le mec il venait
tranquillement il a livré alerté par des
cris une voisine décide de filmer la
scène
l'agresseur s'en prend verbalement à
elle à visage découvert avec des
insultes racistes ainsi que des menaces
et personne ne touche même avec un
problème avec un doigt de kate bush pas
gros chien tu pue la pisse tu pues la
mer pendant 800 vous a pondu comme tu
peux pas je suis bien trop man 2 on a
annoncé qu'on sait c'est fort c'est
peut-être normal et c'est fort c'est
quelque chose qui étaient pleines dents
larmes
je t'ai pas l équité traumatise s'était
pas fort d'esprit dont je me suis dit on
pas su installer
depuis une enquête judiciaire a été
ouverte
et selon le journal le parisien le
suspect a été retrouvé et interpellé par
la police mardi
l'homme âgé d'une vingtaine d'années est
à l'intérimaire qui contrairement à
certaines rumeurs ne travaille pas dans
l'établissement de restauration
il s'y rend dimanche soir pour manger
avant de retourner à l'hôtel où il loge
à côté suite au refus de se faire servir
en raison du couvre feu
le suspect s'en prend aux livreurs après
des échanges verbaux diffusés sur les
réseaux sociaux
la vidéo fait rapidement le buzz et les
associations antiracisme s'empare du
sujet aux veines justice que justice
soit rendue
or la soeur pour les noirs qui ont été
insultée parce que ce n'est pas
seulement un peu pour cette personne
c'est tous les mois les humains nous
sommes des humains victime de critiques
et de menaces le restaurant brasco a
décidé de porter plainte et la
préfecture a pris un arrêté de fermeture
administrative d'une durée de sept jours
prise en charge par les pompiers qui ont
constaté plusieurs plaies le livreur a
lui aussi décidé de porter plainte
une démarche copié par la voisine suite
aux agressions verbales et aux menaces
c'est une affaire qui pose pas mal de
questions elle met en lumière un tabou
français le racisme entre communautés
étrangères l'émergence d'une violence
décomplexée et l'échec peut-être du
système d'intégration à la française
autant de questions dont on va débattre
ce soir avec nos invités
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler ghislain veut
de président du cran le conseil
représentatif des associations noires de
france bonsoir merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés nadir caillat président de
l'association banlieues plus mon soir à
vous aussi merci d'être avec nous un mot
tout d'abord pour avoir votre sentiment
c'est avec les mots font mal à on l'est
on les entend dans cette vidéo de la
violence gratuite pour vous tout
simplement du racisme bête et méchant
j'espère veut d'eux tout d'abord il faut
dire qu'il ne faut pas d' amalgame
panama gamme
il ne faut pas opposer ici les
communautés et pour parler crûment il ne
faudrait pas opposé des noirs et des
arabes
il faudrait il faut d'abord saluer la
dignité des personnes qui se sont
réunies à cergy hier et il faut dire que
ces personnes étaient de toutes les
couleurs
ces personnes étaient blanches elle
était noire elle était d'origine nord
africaine
donc il ne faut pas un amalgame ensuite
il ya deux problèmes le problème
le premier problème est celui des
travailleurs ce qui sont exploités par
le réseau hubert un moment il faudra
parler de ce problème là parce que
normalement tout employeur doit protéger
ses salariés ça c'est le premier
problème donc un salarié a été agressé
et donc son employeur devrait le
protéger
deuxième problème bien évidemment ces
propos racistes et on ne discute pas
avec des propos racistes
on les condamne et donc ce monsieur a
été retrouvé et le cran est en train de
d'agir pour porter l affaire en justice
et être partie civile parce que c'est la
justice qui doit sanctionner ce là votre
réaction nadir khayat parce que ce lien
entre voilà on a du mal à trouver les
mots mais entre avant la violence entre
les communautés étrangères on appelle ça
comme on veut mais enfin on va en parler
mais ce débat il vient pas des médias on
va le voir
dans la bouche des responsables
politiques on va parler aussi d'histoire
mais en fait votre premier sentiment
après en tout cas ce cette vidéo assez
choquant en temps il faut bien le dire
ben je suis je suis un peu comme tout le
monde on est tous été choqué par la
teneur des propos et la violence qui a
subi ce pauvre livreur je pense que
c'était le deuxième cette semaine
malheureusement il ya eu deux trois
livreurs hubert qui ont été violentés
par des individus qui sont
principalement des personnes du camp
dans un quartier populaire et s'est
livré re même sur des personnes très
souvent issus des quartiers populaires
donc ça c'est extrêmement dommageable
après il ya il ya eu des propos qui sont
violents parce qu'il sait les propos
racistes qui ont été tenus envers cette
femme il ya eu cette violence vis-à-vis
du chauffeur donc je pense que tout le
monde condamne ce type de propos cette
violence après je ne pense pas qu'il ya
de tabou en france simplement il ya des
sujets qu'on compare qui ne sont pas mis
en avant comme d'autres parce que il ya
des racismes qui sont puissants plus
important plus fort et plus plus visible
mais il ya aussi des racismes comme là
on a pu le voir à travers des minorités
puis c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
savoir dénoncer très rapidement alors
une association est monté au créneau en
tout au long de la journée
la licra par la voix de m galina elbaz
les présidents de la commission
discrimination de la licra écouter avant
de poursuivre ce débat on se rend compte
que ça touche maintenant des populations
qui sont elles mêmes victimes de racisme
ce qu'il y a de nouveau dans ce type de
propos racistes c'est l'évocation de
l'esclavagisme la traite négrière arabo
musulmane dans les livres d'histoire
c'est un phénomène qui passe un peu de
côté
cette vidéo met en évidence un racisme
méconnu viacom jeudi ans ce lien
effectivement m game lina el baz
le fait avec une page de l'histoire peut
être méconnu il s'agit de la traite
orientale c'est un racisme méconnu c'est
un fait déjà méconnu ghislain veut d'eux
qu'ils aient reçu orgie
malencontreusement je crois qu'ici il ne
faut surtout pas d'amalgamé je voulais
rappeler que beaucoup d'associations
nord-africaine et aussi qui défend les
droits des arabo musulmans nous ont
contactés pour dénoncer cela et dire que
en aucune façon cette personne ne
représente la commune est ému
arabo-musulmane et nord africaines ça
c'est la première chose à dire il ne
faudrait pas tomber dans ces amalgames
et bien sûr pour dire les choses crûment
il ya des cons partout il ya des cons
qu'ils sont noirs il est conquis son
blanc il ya des clans les cons qu'ils
sont juifs et des cons qui sont nord
africain est donc cette personne a
commis une agression et aussi des propos
racistes qui sont sanctionnables par la
loi et donc il faudrait pas faire
l'amalgamé
il ne faudrait pas associer cette
personne a toute une ensemble tout un
ensemble de communautés qui n'ont rien
demandé et qui sanctionne cela dans leur
majorité
alors on reparle de cet enseignement de
cette période de l'histoire n'avait pas
exactement répondu à cette question on a
compris qu'il fallait pas d'amalgamé
nous on ne veut pas en faire sur ce
plateau mais on essaye quand même de
comprendre peut-être ce phénomène qu'on
ignorait peut-être que c'est un fait
isolé mais essayons d'approfondir
souvenez-vous notamment de cette petite
phrase de christiane taubira c'était en
2006 écouter il ne faut pas trop évoquer
la traite négrière arabo musulmane pour
que les jeunes arabes ne porte pas sur
leur dos tout le poids de l'héritage des
méfaits des arabes nadir khayat
quelle réaction alors moi je suis je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord moi je
suis pour la transparence totale
aujourd'hui on vit une époque très
difficile où les français s'affrontent
en permanence notamment à cause du jeu
malsain dead et du rassemblement
national et de certains médias
malheureusement qui ne donne la parole
cassez cassez extrêmes de droite mais
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut tous
diront vie n'est pas certes difficile
mais moi même en tant que français mais
également franco algérien maghrébins
musulmans
je suis pour tout dire depuis la nuit
des temps l'esclave âge
a toujours existé malheureusement toutes
les toutes les grandes civilisations ont
eu affaire à ça malheureusement
et oui il ya eu des arabes qui est des
arabo-musulmans qui ont qui ont
participé à l'esclavagé s'il faut le
dire je le reconnais et nous en tout cas
moi en tant que musulman je le reconnais
qui on le condamne évidemment parce que
ça fait pas partie de notre religion
vous avez aussi des chrétiens et
d'autres communautés qui ont participé à
ça aussi malheureusement à des périodes
différentes
mais aujourd'hui je pense qu'on est
suffisamment mûre pour de se dire les
choses et tout cet ensemble pour
condamner ça parce qu'on est dans une
société multiculturelle avec des
histoires parfois différentes mais c'est
important aussi d'être tous ensemble
face à ce type de comportement
mais je pense aussi que pour compléter
ce que vous êtes en train de dire il
faut aussi et recontextualiser alors si
on veut parler d'histoire remettre dans
le temps et dans l'espace
et malheureusement quand on parle de
traite arabo musulmane c'est souvent
aussi pour masquer ce qui se passe en
occident
aujourd'hui il ne faudrait pas importer
des débats qui devraient être traités
dans certains espaces pour les importer
en france aujourd'hui en france c'est
vrai qu'on lutte contre toutes les
formes de racisme on lutte contre la
traite négrière qui a eu lieu entre
l'europe la france l'afrique et les
amériques
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu aussi cette
traite négrière arabo musulmane mais il
faudrait pas se tromper l'espace il
faudrait pas se tromper de débat et ici
il ne s'agit pas de ce débat là le
racisme entre communautés c c'est
quelque chose qui n'existe pas pour vous
on à dire callas c'est donc un fait
isolé ce qui s'est passé
cette fin dimanche pardon non non mais
ils y achètent pas s'illusionner ya
quelques années il ya eu des problèmes
dans 93 du côté de aubervilliers bobigny
avec des communautés asiatiques étaient
régulièrement agressé par des jeunes de
cité qui s'en prenaient à eux et qu'ils
pouvaient tenir des propos racistes
envers cette communauté
la réalité si vous voulez aujourd'hui
c'est bien de réagir à un buzz et
condamner ce type de faits c'est très
bien mais à un moment donné il faut
aller aux sondes des problèmes et
notamment de la situation en france
maintenant si on veut régler ces
problèmes là il faut se dire tout il
faut se dire qu'aujourd'hui les
quartiers populaires c'est plus possible
de mettre des gens ensemble et d'imposer
un communautarisme et après de le
montrer du doigt en disant oui mais
regardez ces gens là sont très
communautaire alors que tout est fait
politiquement socialement et comme moi
pour que ces gens vivent entre eux il
faut se dire les choses aujourd'hui
c'est plus possible il faut démanteler
les quartiers populaires il faut créer
de la vraie mixité sociale comme elle
existait dans les années 70 début 80 en
france
il faut dénoncer les propos racistes qui
perdure aujourd'hui dans les médias et
qui sont devenus la norme de beaucoup de
politiques à droite comme à gauche
aujourd'hui et ces tensions rappelle
simplement cette situation que vivent la
plupart des français issus de
l'immigration ou pas aujourd'hui à des
choses qu'il faut savoir dénoncer pour
si vous voulez pérenniser le vivre
ensemble qu'il existait une époque et
qui est de plus en plus difficile
aujourd'hui parce que politiquement rien
n'est fait pour créer une vraie mixité
sociale à la hauteur des enjeux et
ghislain veut cette mixité sociale se
mélangent ça existait effectivement
avant aussi peut-être dans les cités est
ce qu'aujourd'hui toutes les sortes de
communautés si j'ose dire ont du mal à
se mélanger peut-être elle se mélange
bien qu'avant qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est la grosse aujourd'hui alors
aujourd'hui il faut faire attention à la
politisation du débat il n'a échappé à
personne qu'on est dans une période pré
électorale et donc que ce genre
d'incident va être récupérée par les
extrêmes et donc ce qu'il est important
de dire aujourd'hui c'est que oui quand
on met un maximum de personnes
paupérisée des personnes les plus
pauvres issus souvent de l'immigration
dans les mêmes environnements et bien ça
crée des tensions
et bien il ne faudrait pas pour autant
qu'on puisse cacher la réalité de ces
problèmes
aujourd'hui à des institutions qui font
leur travail il faut rappeler que quand
des incidents comme ça se passe comme ce
qui s'est passé hier
eh bien il ya des sanctions ce jeune
homme a été arrêté mais il ne faudrait
pas juste se concentrer sur ce jeune
homme
il ya un phénomène plus globale il faut
faire attention récupération politique
et ne faudrait pas justement encenser ce
genre d'événement pour ne pas justement
faire en sorte que les les les personnes
qui sont déjà à paupériser puisse encore
ressentir encore plus de paupérisation
donc nous avons un devoir de
responsabilité j'insiste un devoir de
responsabilité et notre devoir est de
rappeler qu'il faut se concentrer sur
l'essentiel et l'essentiel c'est de
rappeler que dans les quartiers à des
gens qui vit qui sont de toutes les
origines
blanc noir nord africaine asiatique et
que toutes ces personnes condamne cela
condamne cela mais j'en reviens à ma
question s'entendent aussi bien qu'avant
on dit souvent que le modèle
d'intégration à la française se déchire
un petit peu pour devenir un modèle à
l'anglo saxonne c'est ce que vous
constatez sur le terrain nadir khayat
pour en parler oui pendant les je suis
moi ce que je peux dire c'est que plus
on va vous redonner la parole au geste
avait donc on va laisser effectivement
répondu on vous donnera la parole
globalement globalement les gens
malheureusement entre guillemets vis
très bien ensemble dans les quartiers
populaires après il peut y avoir des
périodes où il ya des tensions dues à
des faits divers mais globalement et
malheureusement il vit très bien
ensemble
mais aujourd'hui on impose ce vivre
ensemble dans les quartiers et donc il
peut il peut y avoir de temps en temps
des faits comme ça et comme l'a dit
monsieur très justement il y avait
récupération politique est aujourd'hui
la vraie question c'est comment on peut
on peut changer ça mais il n'y a pas de
volonté je vous donne un exemple assez
concret et je remercie arte france pour
nous avoir invités ça va faire deux
jours qu'il y à ce débat médiatique et
politique
et quand vous regardez les certains
médias ah bah vous verrez pas de
personnes issues des quartiers
populaires vous verrez pas de maghrébins
ou de noir à la télé pour parler de ces
sujets là tout en sachant que c'est les
sujets qui les concernent en premier
vous avez toujours les mêmes personnes
qui apparaissent dans les grands médias
et qui parlent de la banlieue sans la
banlieue ou l'immigration sans les
personnes concernées et c'est ça qui est
aussi violent en terme en termes de en
terme d'image de renvoyer cette
france-là keane qui n'apparaît pas d'un
côté mais qui est de l'autre côté et
puis qu'on pointe du doigt donc je
remercie vraiment arte france
donner la parole et de passer ce message
aux uns et aux autres
aujourd'hui dans les quartiers
populaires au delà de ce fait divers les
gens vivent très bien ensemble mais il
faut changer ça parce qu'aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas imposer à des français issus
de l'immigration veut continuer à vivre
comme ça dans les conditions qui sont
pas normales et qui sont injustes des
valeurs de la république notamment celle
qui est prônée par les politiques en
permanence au quotidien et dans les
médias ghislain bleus le mot de la fin
et je vous laisse vous exprimer sur ce
que vous voyez nous dire il ya quelques
instants
exactement on peut parler des quartiers
et moi je suis très bien plat pas placé
pour en parler puisque j'étais éducateur
dans les quartiers pendant très
longtemps et dans les quartiers les
différentes communautés comme on les
appelle politiquement vivent très bien
ensemble et bien la question qui se pose
ici c'est toujours de quel point de vue
on parle de quel point de vue on part et
quand on donne la parole
systématiquement à des personnes qui ne
vivent pas dans ces quartiers et qu'ils
viennent instrumentaliser cette parole
là là il ya un problème
donc aujourd'hui effectivement y ait des
personnes ou si on va dans le xvième
si on va dans le 20e si on va dans le
18e si on va à sarcelles à cergy oui il
ya des agressions
oui comme ça se passe ailleurs mais la
question qu'il faut sortir de cette
parole la question qu'il faut se poser
c'est de quel point de vue on parle à
qui est ce qu'on donne la parole
effectivement vous nous donnez la parole
pour en parler puisque nous sommes les
personnes concernées c'est une très
bonne chose mais ce qu'on regarde
politiquement par qui et
instrumentaliser ce débat on se rend
compte que ce débat n'est pas assumant
talise et par les personnes concernées
et je le rappelle les institutions font
leur travail et les personnes qui
commettent ces abus sont sanctionnés et
c'est ça qui est important de rappeler
mais surtout de dire qu'il ne faut pas
d' amalgame
merci en tout cas tous les deux jusque
là on veut de et nadir khayat d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur ft france
l'assemblée nationale d'examiner ce
mardi le projet de loi anti terroriste
visant à durcir les mesures autour des
condamnés pour terrorisme
dans ce texte est notamment prévu un
encadrement suivant la sortie des
détenus ayant pris part à des actes
terroristes
un projet de loi jugée trop laxiste pour
la droite au contraire liberticide pour
une partie de la gauche gérald darmanin
eric dupond moretti se sont exprimés
dans l'hémicycle affirmant que cette loi
à concilier vigilance et protection des
libertés loin des promesses d'estrade de
l'opposition à côté le garde des sceaux
expliquer la nécessité de ce projet dont
cet engagement qui est le nôtre contre
le terrorisme islamiste
je viens portée devant vous l'objectif
que s'est fixé la chancellerie réduire
au maximum la menace des personnes
condamnées pour des actes de terrorisme
qui présenteraient encore alors que leur
peine arrives tu à terme des signes de
dangerosité
parce que notre action doit s'adapter à
des réalités mouvante il convient de se
confronter un constat nous sommes
nombreux à avoir fait depuis un certain
temps d'ici la fin de l'année 2024 163
personnes actuellement détenues pour
acte de terrorisme en lien avec la
mouvance islamique auront purgé leur
peine
parmi elles un certain nombre présentons
sans doute encore des signes de
radicalisation
al'approche de cette échéance je tiens à
saluer avec force la qualité du travail
engagé au quotidien dans nos
établissements pénitentiaires pour
prévenir la radicalisation
il nous faut dire que ce sont
précisément ces mêmes détenus ici le
droit n'est pas modifiée pour bénéficier
d'une mesure de surveillance judiciaire
lorsqu'ils seront libérés sont suivis
sans accompagnement
le projet de loi anti terroriste on en
parle avec alexis poulain c'est notre
rubrique l'édito
[Musique]
bonsoir alexis à kunar le projet de loi
antiterroriste examiné donc à
l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui
pour commencer un petit peu de factuel
que prévoit ce texte alors c'est un
texte qui était prévu de longue date qui
n'est pas un texte porte unissent tous
pour réviser la loi s'il qu'un sécurité
intérieure et lutte contre le terrorisme
et compléter celles sur le renseignement
de 2015 après les attentats terroristes
donc on voit bien que elle s'inscrit
dans une longue suite de texte on parle
même de depuis 35 ans de plus de 36 loi
antiterroriste qui s'accumulent là le
gouvernement et la majorité proposent
effectivement de contrôler davantage la
sortie des détenus éviter ce qu'on
appelle les sorties sèches de détenus
condamnés pour terrorisme
avec le passage d'un an à deux ans des
mesures individuelles de contrôle
administratif et puis une mesure
judiciaire de réinsertion sociale
antiterroriste c'est ce que disait le
garde des sceaux
il ya également du côté des services de
renseignement un régime particulier qui
se mettrait en place de conservation des
informations de connexion des url de
connexion de données via l'algorithme
qui permettrait via une ia de contrôler
un peu les sites de radicalisation ou
autres qu'utilisent les uns et les
autres les données de navigation des
français sur internet alors existe-t-il
alex est un risque pour les libertés
individuelles parce que c'est une
critique qui revient souvent
on peut se poser la question c'est vrai
qu'on a l'impression que ces lois
s'accumulent un arbre et mille feuille
administratif comme d'habitude un je le
disais depuis 35 ans 36 loi
antiterroriste qui s'accumulent au nom
de la menace terroriste
avec toujours l'appeler prérogatives
d'un état de surveillance total qui
gagne sur l'état de droit
aujourd'hui vous aviez raphaël gauvin
qui est co rapporteur de cette loi pour
la république en marche qui parle d'une
ligne de crête entre l'ordre public et
les libertés individuelles et même le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
qui lui reconnaît que sur le plan
constitutionnel la majorité prend un
risque puisqu'elle pourrait être
sanctionné par le conseil
constitutionnel
mais aujourd'hui les choses ont changé
on peut dire que le contexte joue en
faveur de ce texte
les agressions qui se multiplient contre
les forces de l'ordre encore tout
récemment à nantes le meurtre d'un
enseignant samuel pâtit le meurtre
également s'était pas nîmes ont fermé à
rambouillet une policière par un
terroriste islamiste
donc on voit bien que les menaces se
multiplient non seulement via le
terrorisme radicaliser islamistes mais
aussi terrorisme d'extrême droite avec
ces derniers jours c'est celle où lâchés
dans la nature qui tirait contre les
gendarmes et on ne sait pas combien
pourrait passer à l'acte donc on voit
bien qu'il y avait nécessité et au delà
de l'actualité il ya la réalité 163
détenus condamnés pour terrorisme qui
vont sortir d'ici 2024
il va bien falloir les surveiller parce
que une fois sortis ils resteront
radicaux malgré les tentatives de
déradicalisation qui ont échoué malgré
tout tout ce qui a été mis en oeuvre au
sein des instituts pénitentiaire il va
falloir surveiller
au delà de la fiche sc personnes
dangereuses pour la société et qui vont
être relâchés dans la nature alors à
droite on veut aller plus loin certains
veulent changer la constitution c'est le
cas d'eric ciotti mais aussi guillaume
pelletier qu'on a entendu ce week-end
qui parlait d'une cour spéciale de la
république une cour de sûreté qui serait
sans appel qui permettrait de condamner
ces décès ces responsables d'actes
terroristes et là on parle d'une
juridiction d'exception une sorte de
boîte un hameau du droit qui a choqué à
gauche mais aussi à droite
et puis à gauche la france a soumises en
tête on tire larmes bien sûr sur les
libertés individuelles en disant qu'il
va falloir revoir cette loi aujourd'hui
ces 443 amendements qui ont été déposés
par rapport à ce projet de loi mais bien
sûr il va elle continuait d'être étudiée
dans les jours qui viennent
alexis ponnet avec vous évidemment on
parle souvent des répercussions sur un
certaines campagnes de 2022 quelles
implications jeu se monte ce projet de
loi 107 campagne oui c'est sûr que ce
n'est pas
non plus anodin que c'est toi ça veut
discuter à un an des élections
présidentielles
évidemment c'est un thème la security
qui va être au centre des débats pour la
présidentielle et qui joue en faveur
bien sûr du rassemblement national qui
milite pour davantage de mesures de
contrôle davantage de mesures de
sécurité et de sûreté depuis des années
donc ça va dans le sens évidemment de
marine le pen sans qu'elle ait à faire
quoi que ce soit mais ça va au delà
également de cette campagne
présidentielle puisqu'on pose des
questions de fond finalement sur la
place de l'état de droit par rapport à
l'état d'exception qui devient la norme
on a l'impression que depuis 2010 est
avec cette entrée dans la loi de l'état
d'exception est bien on pousse toujours
plus loin
la surveillance technologique la
surveillance globale
l'algorithme à une sorte de police à
rigaud rythmique issue verrait tous les
français des drones qu'on a voulu faire
voler pendant le confinement que le
conseil constitutionnel a sanctionné
mais qui pourrait revenir avec la loi
sécurité globale comme si finalement
l'état d'exception devenait la norme est
acceptée dans les moeurs par tous mais
ça pose une question fondamentale sur
l'esprit finalement des lois est ce que
nous restons encore une démocratie
libérale ou ce que nous entrons dans un
autre régime aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que personne ne veut poser
la question et pourtant elle est
centrale dans les débats de 2022
les technologies de surveillance doit
être contrôlée par le droit le droit ne
doit pas s'adapter
finalement à ces technologies qui vont
entrer dans nos vies quotidiennes
et là ça va de pair non seulement avec
ces lois antiterroristes
mais avec ce qu'on voit sur le pass
sanitaires sur les lois sanitaire qui
ressemble aussi à des lois de contrôle
algorithmique et cette question là je
pense sur le modèle de démocratie
libérale elle est éludée par les
législateurs qui pensent faire bien pour
la sécurité de tous et qui peut-être
sont en train d'enterrer notre modèle
d'organisation politique depuis des
années merci alexis pour l'un d'avoir
été avec nous elle reste avec nous dans
quelques instants à
sur cette question qui fait débat
doit-on vacciner des adolescents en
agence européenne des médicaments elle a
en tout cas a donné son feu vert pour
les 12 15 ans et puis nous irons en
malaisie comme ses voisins du sud est
asiatique le pays impose un confinement
strict sa population face à une hausse
importante des quatre copines
[Musique]
en octobre 2020 l'exécutif européen a
présenté une directive relative à des
salaires minimaux adéquat dans l'union
européenne
objectif combattre la pauvreté chacun
des pays européens est face à une montée
des inégalités et à alimenter très
violente de la pauvreté et l exclusion
on est en train de s'occuper d'un
salaire minimum alors que le problème
c'est que une fois déjà trouvé un moyen
pour faire baisser le chômage parce que
les chômeurs il s'inflige du salaire
minimum
ils n'ont pas de travail donc ils n'ont
pas de salaire ghosn a un problème de
développement économique il s'agit pas
d'imposer un smic à des pays tu veux pas
les moyens tout simplement d'y faire
face
vous avez quand même pas mal d'étudiants
ont été faites justement sur le smic en
disant que le smic
écarté du marché du travail les gens peu
qualifiés on peut se poser aussi la
question de savoir si réellement c'est
une bonne idée
et en féminicide et commis tous les deux
à trois jours en france actuellement
pourquoi il joue ton encore à protéger
totalement les femmes on dit souvent
femmes osé en parler
briser le silence nous savons que
seulement 18 19 % des femmes révèle les
violences qu'elles subissent donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya 80% de femmes qui ne
révèle pas les violences qu'elles
subissent aux forces de sécurité dont
celle qui rêvait il faut vraiment les
croix et les protéger souvent on met
toute la responsabilité sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi le dis
très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement on voit bien
qu'on est quand même encore très loin
très loin de ce qui est nécessaire pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir les moyens de
protéger les femmes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
et y'a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi que dès qu'on
dit il n'y a pas d'alternative au temps
du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose de
dignité gilet jaune c'était des valeurs
de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soient pas publics
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
le théâtre du châtelet c'est par théâtre
comme les autres c'est un théâtre qui
est très diversifiée dans un
programmation de la culture est une
activité absolument essentiel de notre
société de sa cohésion de sa cohérence
c'est aussi le rôle du châtelet de
pouvoir mettre en contact des très
belles productions avec le public
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans un théâtre en
plein confinement on a essayé de
réinventer notre métier et en
particulier on a fait beaucoup de
travail avec la télévision où on a
permis de capter un certain nombre de
spectacles pour la télévision ce qui est
une autre manière de pouvoir créer la
relation avec le public je suis sûr
qu'il y aura une grande volonté du
public de revenir dans les théâtres
[Musique]
oh
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre en
direct sur rt france pour cette deuxième
heure d'émission tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce mardi 1er
juin plus de 25 millions de français ont
reçu au moins une injection de vaccin
contre le coc vide mais certaines
tranches d'âge comme les plus de 70 et
80 ans accuse du retard concernant les
adolescents la france attend l'avis de
la haute autorité de santé cette semaine
l'académie de médecine y est favorable
d'où cette question faut-il vraiment
vacciner les adolescents y at il urgence
ce sera l'objet de notre décryptage
le chef du front polisario entendu par
le tribunal espagnol ce matin brahim
ghali visé par deux plaintes pour
torture et génocide si le procès est au
centre d'une crise diplomatique entre
l'espagne et le maroc
le juge n'a pas le moment adopté aucune
mesure comme la confiscation de ses
papiers ou sa détention provisoire
son avocat a nié toutes les accusations
[Musique]
c'est une notion part entière à la
volonté de l'actuel premier ministre
québécois françois légaux il souhaite
inscrire dans la constitution que les
québécoises et des québécois forment une
nation et que les français le français
soit la seule langue officielle du
québec est la langue commune
le premier ministre canadien lui est
favorable à cette évolution
institutionnelle
[Musique]
la crise sanitaire en france est tout
d'abord cette polémique autour de stocks
de masques ffp2 le ministre en appelant
rappel des millions potentiellement
dangereux sauf que près de 17 millions
déjà été distribués aux soignants la
présence de graphène un élément
potentiellement toxique inquiète et
interrogent sur le rôle de l'état dans
cette commande en pleine crise du coc
vide des scènes celle des masques censés
nous protéger qui se retrouve au coeur
d'une polémique dont le gouvernement se
serait bien passé en cause le graphène
ce nanomatériau composant principal de
ces ffp2 pourtant présenté comme
révolutionnaire par les industriels et
le centre national de la recherche
scientifique ultra-résistant ultra-léger
imperméable on lui a même trouvé des
propriétés antivirales en avril 2020 le
gouvernement commande à la chine plus de
60 millions de ces masques ffp2 des
masses qui livrait avec une notice dont
les détails ont apparemment échappé aux
autorités de santé près de 17 millions
de ces masques distribués aux soignants
sont rappelés parce que jugée
potentiellement dangereux
le 25 mai dernier et santé publique
france publie une note destinée aux
personnels de santé
une note se voulait discrète et qui
passe alors inaperçu urgent informations
de sécurité
votre structure est susceptible d'avoir
été destinataires de masques labellisés
bio masse graphène dans la tente de
l'évaluation de l'éventuel risque est
lié à la présence de graphène dans ces
masques et par précaution il vous est
demandé de ne plus les utiliser
une information rapidement appuyées par
l' agence régionale de santé
ile-de-france dans un document daté du
même jour
à ce stade il a été identifié 60 5
millions de masques ffp2 doté d'un
marquage ce et eux pouvant
potentiellement contenir du graphène
dont 16,9 millions ont d'ores et déjà
été distribuées en 2020 ces masques ont
principalement été distribués aux
établissements de santé et
établissements médico-sociaux leur a
fallu une lettre d' alerte adressée à la
commission européenne par quatre ong
dont les galeries d'art autres armes ou
encore la décision de certains pays
comme le canada de retirer l'ensemble
des ffp2 en circulation sur leur
territoire pour
que les pouvoirs publics prennent enfin
les choses au sérieux ces masques en
polypropylène sont potentiellement
toxiques les laisser sur le marché
pourrait dangereusement ébranlé la
confiance du public dans le port de
masques
deux mois après ces alertes au canada le
gouvernement français prend enfin des
mesures similaires pour appeler
l'ensemble de ces masques alors comment
sont ils arrivés sur le nez des
soignants des hôpitaux de l'hexagone
interrogé par nos confrères de mediapart
santé publique france joue la carte du
mea culpa en avançant que c'est comme en
date d'avril 2020 avec un avis favorable
de l'agencé nationale de la sécurité du
médicament mais que la mention bio masse
graphène semble avoir échappé
pourtant toute notion de biocides
devrait être rédhibitoire comme l'a
expliqué santé publique france
l'utilisation des biocides était un
critère d'exclusion dans le cahier des
charges des autorités sanitaires
ces masques n'aurait donc jamais dû être
distribués aux soignants santé publique
france explique que cette commande avait
été passée en avril 2020 avec un avis
est favorable de la haine s m
pourtant dans le rapport de test ainsi
que dans la notice du fabricant la
mention de biomasse graphène
apparaissait bien reconnaît spf
aujourd'hui il est plus de 43 millions
de masques ffp2 stockées par l'état
voient leur distribution gelé alors
s'agit-il d'une réalité devenue
embarrassante ou bien d'une erreur
d'appréciation
près d'un an et demi après le début de
la crise la france semble vouloir se
voiler la face sur certains aspects de
sa gestion de l'épidémie
on est tous les français de plus de 18
ans qui le veulent sont donc désormais
éligibles à la vaccination contrôle qu
vite se pose désormais la question de la
vaccination des plus jeunes
l'agencé européenne des médicaments a
donné son feu vert vendredi dernier pour
les 12 15 ans vaccin arn messagers de
phison ventech déjà autorisé à partir de
16 ans la france s apprête à le
recommander cette semaine aux jeunes
âgés de 16 à 17 ans alors la vaccination
des adolescents est elle vraiment
nécessaire était urgente
les parents seront ils réfractaires ou
au contraire plutôt encouragé
à pratiquer cette vaccination sur leurs
enfants c'est l'objet de notre
décryptage avec nous pour en parler
pierre tattevin infectiologues chef du
service des maladies infectieuses au chu
de rennes bonsoir pierre tête vient
ainsi d'être avec nous à vos côtés
ricardo carbajal chef du service des
urgences urgences pédiatriques de
l'hôpital armand trousseau à paris bon
soir ricardo carbajal merci d'être avec
nous donc pour les 12 16 ans l agence
européenne du médicament a déjà donné
son feu vert le 28 mai l'académie de
médecine elle la préconisent pour
l'instant pour atteindre l'immunité vous
partager cette analyse pierre tattevin a
vacciné les plus jeunes pour atteindre
cette immunité collective après laquelle
nous courons oui on a bien vu depuis un
an et demi qu'on court après cette
épidémie qu'on n'a pas eu beaucoup de
succès avec les masques avec les tester
votre reportage controversé pas simple
on a maintenant des vaccins qui marche
très bien qui sont bénéfiques pour les
gens qui sont vaccinées mais aussi pour
la collectivité en limitant la
propagation du virus donc je suis très
favorable à ces propositions
ricardo carbajal vous êtes pédiatre
c'est votre spécialisé pareil favorable
sans réserve à la vaccination des plus
jeunes absolument je suis totalement
d'accord avec cette proposition
je pense que il faut voir le problème
non seulement sur les faits dès
protection directe vis-à-vis de la
maladie des enfants parce que là on
pourrait dire que cette maladie n'est
pas très sévère chez la plupart
d'enfants on pourrait trouver celles
incombant n'arrivons pas très fort mais
je pense que et ses visions doit être
beaucoup plus large parce que les
enfants subissent des conséquences non
seulement de la maladie mais des toutes
les conséquences au psychosocial que cet
écartement des enfants des écoles des
privations des contacts avec leur
famille avec les proches
on traîne par cette épidémie et n'est
pas vacciné vingt 120 100 % de la
population parce que ce sont les moins
de 18 ans commence à faire une saison
même s'il fait 15% va être un frein
majeur
l'éradication
carvajal vous vous êtes plutôt à
contre-courant par rapport à vos amis
confrères de la société française de
pédiatrie genou propose de les écouter
lakovic 19 chez l'enfant et le plus
souvent asymptomatique
les enfants sont peu contagieux et très
peu de formes sévères ont été décrites
même pour ceux atteints de pathologies
chroniques
actuellement il n'y a que très peu de
données d'efficacité et de tolérance de
ces vaccins disponibles chez l'enfant
à ce jour cette vaccination n'apparaît
pas comme nécessaire chez l'enfant en
population générale
ça c'est vrai que c'est quand même la
société française de pédiatrie qui le
dit a diet deux idées là dedans et ça on
le savait souvent asymptomatique peu
contagieux et des données d'efficacité
tolérance des vaccins pas vraiment
disponible pour le moment pierre
tattevin qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
répondre à ce genre d'argument de la
part de deux connaissent un art tout de
même oui alors il ya aucun doute sur
l'expertisé les goûts raisonnement la
société française de pédiatrie je pense
que leur position va évoluer
il ya au moins deux choses à dire c'est
qu'on sait que les variants au fil du
temps ont été de plus en plus mauvais
pour les enfants même si c'est pas comme
chez les adultes âgés mais c'est quand
même la troisième vague a été plus
marquée chez les enfants et puis la
deuxième chose c'est qu'on commence à
avoir ses données que la société
française de pédiatrie souhaiterait
avoir sur l'efficacité des vaccins chez
les enfants il ya eu des études chez les
adolescents avec pfizer avec modern
assez des vaccins qui sont moins
embêtant
chez les sujets jeunes que
ponctuellement astrazeneca nous devons
pas trop de raisons de rester à commuter
sur cette position ricardo carbajal
quand on entend ça m'inquiète pédiatre
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec ce
qu'affirme cette société française de
pédiatrie c'est que en gros il n'y a pas
de danger
sur les enfants concernant ce virus et
en plus on a peu de données on parle là
du bénéfice risque qui s'inverse un
petit peu par rapport aux adultes
je pense que connu de cette épidémie
depuis mars 2020 et bien malin celui qui
a un avis péremptoire qui changent pas
la semaine suivante au début de la crise
on a changé trois fois par jour donc en
fait on fait avec l'information que nous
recueillons au fur et à mesure ce qui
vient dire de mon confrère à l'instant
effectivement il ya des articles publiés
dans des grandes revues les nuits glande
d'autres revues très renommé qui vient
démontrer l'efficacité la sécurité avec
les informations dont on dispose des ces
vaccins chez les 12-15 ans avec une
efficacité pour les façades qui a été
détruite la des 100 % donc oui
effectivement on a cet élément-là de
l'efficacité certains nous n'avons pas
encore des milliers et des milliers d
des patients mais dans les patients qui
ont été inclus dans un étude là qui
vient d'être publié il n'y a pas
d'effets secondaires majeurs mais je
pense que c'est un tort de penser
simplement que si la maladie n'est pas
grave
chez ces populations là il n'y a pas
nécessité des ses proches et de vaccins
si l'on à ce moment là on pourra dire la
même chose de la roja
la rougeole pour la plupart d'entre eux
n'est pas une maladie grave mais tu les
grands et les adultes et sont la
vaccination des enfants
bah on ne serait pas au stade des
contentions de cette maladie là et dans
l'histoire de la médecine en pathologie
infectieuse ça a toujours été dit qu'un
donc je pense que à partir du moment
nous avons des doses suffisantes et le
calendrier possible il faut les vaccinés
est à mon sens je dirais même plus ce
n'est pas attendre d'avoir terminé avec
un âge donné pour commencer les enfants
parce qu'il faut être pratico-pratique
nous arrivons dans la période estivale
les vaccinations au mois d'août la
servante très compliqué et nous allons
nous retrouver si nous ne mettons pas en
iran politique assez active probablement
avec un début des vaccinations septembre
en tort et au premier cas des décors un
avis résistance menés kolb on va fermer
et les conséquences psychosociales sont
dramatiques et les sons réels les
l'exclusion des enfants de ces
millionnaires
on va les payer pendant des années et
des années
est ce qu ont assez de recul tout de
même pierre tattevin parce que ça
concerne ces données qui sont peu
disponibles
les experts n'ont étudié n'a été étudié
que pendant 55 jours
ces études d'homologation c'est quand
même peu qu'est ce que vous allez
répondre à ses parents prudent et
parfois récalcitrants et forcément c'est
logique quand on veut protéger ses
enfants au stade où on en est
actuellement il faut vraiment expliqué
il expliqué honnêtement ce que vous
dites est vrai c'est que comme si les
vaccins qu'on n'a pas depuis très
longtemps donc pas énormément de recul
donc il faut expliquer aux parents et je
pense qu'il faut faire comme avec les
adultes c'est à dire leur dire qu'on a
ça qui est disponible pour vous on vous
conseille de le faire et quand on sent
qu'il ya une opposition franche sur leur
libre et on va encore assister plus que
ça ça a été la politique de début c'est
de proposer le vaccin au maximum de
personnes aussi d'avoir la meilleure
couverture vaccinale possible et ça
plutôt bien payés juste ici on s'envoie
population dit clairement et ricardo
cabanas est ce qu'on est dans une
vaccination altruiste on vaccine pour
les autres pour le bien de la
collectivité en partie en partie parce
que ça fait partie de la chaîne mais
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure en fait
les enfants ont un bénéfice si on arrive
à endiguer cette épidémie plus vite plus
les enfants auront des bénéfices donc
les bénéfices ils ne sont pas comme
direct c'est pas simplement un twist
c'est pas simplement pour n'est pas
contaminé par guy mamie et que voilà il
y à cette maladie qui est bien grave et
chez certains indiquent également chez
les écrits psychosociaux sont importants
et un âge qui est celle de l'enfance on
a besoin des vivres des choses qui
peuvent être véhicules seulement à cet
âge là et victor ont pas un livre plus
tard donc c'est pas simplement triste
c'est aussi pour contribuer à endiguer
l'épidémie les plus vite possible
effectivement je vous propose d'écouter
arnaud fontanet p
logistec l'institut pasteur et membre du
conseil scientifique qui nous donne un
argument qui qui va dans votre sens
messieurs écouter projetons nous à
l'automne à ce moment là comme une
grande partie des adultes auront été
protégé les collèges et les lycées
deviendront les principaux lieux de
circulation du virus
il suffirait que des variants encore
plus contagieux entre dans le jeu pour
qu'on connaisse de nouvelles tensions
dans les hôpitaux
ce ne serait pas forcément une quatrième
vague mais le risque de devoir fermer
des établissements scolaires ressurgir
et pierre tattevin ça c'est vrai que
c'est un c'est un argument parce que je
pense que les enfants n'ont pas
forcément bien vécu toutes ces
fermetures de classes
d'une certaine manière il faudrait la
rendre là je sauve car l'an 1 pas
puisqu'on se demande aussi c'est bien de
vacciner mais là est ce qu'il faudrait
la rendent obligatoire selon vous est-ce
que ça risque d'arriver c'est toujours
préférable de réussir à expliquer aux
gens que c'est bénéfique parce que c'est
pour les enfants et puis pour la
population générale est pour l'instant
comme on a de toute façon pas des stocks
infinie on arrive à progresser en
proposant le vaccin à un maximum de gens
et donc maintenant lorsqu'on est vers
les adolescents
ceux qui sont intéressés on leva le
saint ils sont contents les autres que
les regards de tous et s'aperçoivent que
finalement ça se passe plutôt bien
et progressivement ça fait tâche d'huile
on arrive à augmenter la couverture
vaccinale je suis pas monsieur carbajal
vous parliez tout à l'heure des variants
qui pourrait être plus contagieux
peut-être plus dangereux vous n'avez pas
prononcé ce mot pour les enfants mais il
ya tout de même ce ce spectre sans
agiter le chiffon rouge de nouveaux
variants qui pourrait être voilà plus
plus dangereux effectivement pour les
enfants n'est pas à l'abri en tout cas
non non on n'est pas à l'abri mais à
plusieurs à des contaminations plus il y
aura des circulations plus des virus a
la possibilité d'imiter donc plus vite
tandis qu on limite la prolifération
ben moi on aura des chances de voir
apparaître des barioz est pour l'instant
et fort heureusement les vaccins type
arn messagers failles zero moderna on
montrait une efficacité pour des marion
est pas simple
au niveau des anticorps il ya aussi une
immunité cellulaire qui est activée et
pour l'instant l'efficacité est bonne
espérons que ça va continuer dans ce
sens là je voulais juste ajouter quelque
chose je pense que comme nat et la
communication les parents je les vois ça
tous les jours aux urgences quand on
voit un patient ou en réanimation quand
on est impatients qui a 10 12 ans à
prendre s'adresse pas simplement par an
c'est pas un objet c'est pas ne s'est
pas un être qu'on ignore swan explique à
l'emploi et bien avant et je pense qu'à
cet âge là l'information doit être à
donner aux grains font parce que les
enfants ont vécu depuis plus d'un an
cette épidémie et sept sont des êtres
qui ont une opinion qui ont une
connaissance de ce qu'ils vivent et
subissent les conséquences
je pense que toute campagne qui aurait
fait des bras cibler les enfants aussi
bien sur la connaissance sont en
formation mais également sa fierté
il ya dans l'histoire de la médecine une
campagne qui avait été fait aux états
unis il ya longtemps sur la rougeole
il avait fait un jeu de mots et c'était
la rumeur et l'enbrel en fait c'est à
dire c'était le parapluie contre la
rougeole et isabey réussi à motiver les
enfants parce qu'il tirait une fierté et
ils avaient des cartes des présentations
et il les enfants avaient été les
moteurs pour cela va signer pour un
grand grand pourcentage de la population
parce qu'il avait pris conscience qu'ils
avaient un rôle actif et qu'ils étaient
capables et des pensées et des décidé à
12 ans on n'est pas un petit enfant on a
une capacité plus encore quand on a 15
ans pour effectivement merci ricardo
carbajal et pierre tattevin d'avoir
accepté ce débat en direct ce décryptage
en direct sur arte france
et direction présent la malaisie où la
situation sanitaire lyoko vite se
dégradent malheureusement ce qui
contraint le gouvernement à prendre de
nouvelles mesures les précisions de
julien du rô le que 8,19 n'a pas dit son
dernier mot en asie du sud est
c'est notamment le cas en malaisie où la
flambée des cas inquiète
près de 8000 nouvelles infections sont
comptabilisés quotidiennement avec de
nouveaux records à déplorer chaque jour
pour ce pays de 32 millions d'habitants
le 10 mai dernier le gouvernement avait
pourtant décidé de prendre des mesures
de confinement partiel avant l'aïd
el-fitr
dans un pays où la majorité de la
population est musulmane les données et
la science ont montré que les
rassemblements qui rendait la
distanciation sociale difficile et la
présence de personnes dans des espaces
encombrées étaient les principales
causes de transmission de kobe 19 la
chaîne d'infection ducobu 19 ne peut
être brisé quand encourageant les gens à
rester chez eux grâce à un contrôle
strict des déplacements
malgré ces mesures la situation s'est
depuis aggravée sur les 2800 décès liés
aux covit 19 que ressource le pays 40%
ont eu lieu en ce mois de mai
le gouvernement a donc pris la décision
d'imposer un confinement plus strict
depuis mardi et ce jusqu'au 14 juin
d'ici là tous les rassemblements seront
interdits et les déplacements entre
états soumis à autorisation les
restaurants eux ne fonctionneront
qu'avec la vente à emporter
l'existence de nouveaux variants
agressif avec un taux de contagiosité
plus haut et plus rapide
influencé cette décision avec
l'augmentation des cas quotidiens les
capacités des hôpitaux du pays pour la
prise en charge des patients covit 19
est devenu plus limité en matière de
vaccination le pays accuse un très grand
retard seulement 6 % de la population a
reçu au moins une dose afin d'accélérer
la campagne le tout premier centre de
vaccination ouvert ce dimanche dans la
capitale kuala lumpur
et le vietnam lui s'isole après la
découverte d'un nouveau variant qui se
transmettrait plus rapidement dans l'air
depuis hier au chi minh ville la plus
grande ville du pays est soumise un
nouveau tour de vis avec l'interdiction
de toute activité d'un et social un
confinement total est par ailleurs
appliquée dans les quartiers de la ville
les plus touchés quand un mot claire des
images de tests massif en boucle à la
télévision depuis quelques jours un vent
de panique a pris de l'ampleur au
vietnam la faute à l'apparition d'un
nouveau variant alors que les chiffres
de contamination se sont envolés depuis
plusieurs semaines selon le gouvernement
cette nouvelle forme du coronavirus
serait une combinaison entre les
variants indien et britanniques
ce lundi dans les rues du pays les
vietnamiens ne cachaient pas leur peur
face à cette mutation du virus
je suis très inquiète au sujet du
nouveau variant du virus
je m'efforce de changer mes masques plus
qu'avant quand je sors et je limite les
interactions avec les gens le nouveau
variant et bray du virus me rend très
anxieuse notamment parce qu'il peut se
propager plus vite dans l'air alors
quand je suis dans un endroit clos comme
un ascenseur ou un bureau je suis plus
inquiète parce que si j'attrape l'écho
vite 10,9
je ne sais pas qui est la source directe
de l'infection
[Musique]
les autorités vietnamiennes ont recensé
plus de 7200 cas depuis le début de la
pandémie
signe de la nouvelle vague épidémique
1830 deux personnes ont été testées
positives la semaine dernière à hô chi
minh ville centre économique du pays
les habitants ont reçu l'ordre de ne
plus sortir de chez eux lors des deux
prochaines semaines
sauf déplacement est essentielle les
commerces non essentiels de la ville
sont quant à eux fermés depuis jeudi
dernier
de son côté l'autorité de l'aviation
civile du vietnam a annoncé ce lundi la
suspension temporaire de l'arrivée de
vols internationaux dans deux de ces
aéroports
conformément aux instructions du comité
national de lutte anti qu'ovide 10,9 de
la direction des transports
le département de l'aviation
vietnamienne ordonne d'arrêter
provisoirement les vols internationaux
transportant des passagers à l'aéroport
international no bail de hanoi à compter
du 1er juin 2021 minuit et jusqu'au 7
juin inclus dans le même temps la
suspension de l'arrivée de vols
internationaux à destination de
l'aéroport international tente sa natte
de hô chi minh et prolongé au 14 juin
2021 inclus au lieu du 4 juin 2021
depuis la fin avril l'épidémie s'est
propagée dans trente et une municipalité
ou provinces du pays
les autorités vietnamiennes prévoit de
tester l'ensemble des 9 millions
d'habitants de hô chi minh ville
d'après le quotidien national vietnam
news un objectif de 100 mille tests par
jour est prévu pour cette opération
d'envergure en amérique du sud le pérou
a désormais le plus haut taux mondial de
décès liés aux commis 19 les autorités
ont dévoilé hier
les dernières données de la pandémie le
bilan humain a été réévaluée il passe de
69 milles à 180 mille morts face à des
chiffres jusqu'ici largement sous-évalué
les péruviens sont en colère en pleine
élection présidentielle well in belani
dans les cimetières de lima la longue
procession des enterrements des scènes
devenues quotidiennes pour les habitants
de la capitale péruvienne
le pérou est aujourd'hui à la croisée
des chemins
celui de la dure réalité et du déni
depuis quelques heures
le pays détient le triste record du plus
grand nombre de décès par million
d'habitants nous considérons qu'il est
de notre devoir de rendre publiques ces
informations actualisées non seulement
dans le cadre de notre engagement de
transparence mais aussi pour remplir nos
obligations en tant qu'etat avec plus de
180 mille morts désormais recensés le
pérou dépasse la hongrie pays
jusqu'ici le plus touchée en proportion
de sa population
des chiffres réévalué suite à la mise en
place en avril dernier d'un conseil
technique composé d'experts péruvien et
de spécialistes de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
sept nouveaux critères plus larges ont
fait leur apparition pour comptabiliser
les décès avec notamment la prise en
compte de cas suspect de kovy 19
présentant un cadre cliniques
compatibles avec la maladie jusqu'ici
les autorités sanitaires père vienne se
concentrer uniquement sur les cas
confirmés par des tests positifs avec un
chiffre aussi bas 60 et quelques
milliers
je pense que les gens se sentait assez
confiant et ils n'ont pas pris les
mesures nécessaires
il n'a pas été possible de la contrôler
la pandémie parce que nous avions un
système de santé précaire avant cela
donc quand un système de santé n'est pas
bon avec n'importe quel on dénie aux
pandémies le système de santé s'effondre
s'est effondré au pérou la crise
sanitaire et économique au centre des
élections présidentielles le second tour
est prévu dimanche prochain
après six mois de crise politique et
l'instauration d'un gouvernement de
transition
le candidat communiste pedro
qu'est-ce-qui eau et la représentante de
la droite keiko fujimori ont promis de
venir en aide
en plus de 3 millions de péruviens
tomber dans la pauvreté avec la pandémie
l'objectif est maintenant de vacciner
sont concernés les 24 millions d'adultes
de plus de 18 ans aujourd'hui 5 %
seulement de la population péruvienne a
reçu au moins une dose alors que la
compagne de vaccination a été lancée en
février dernier reste avec nous dans
quelques instants apparemment l'audition
de brahim ghali face à la justice
espagnole le jeu n'a pas confisquer les
papiers du leader du front polisario
l'homme est à nouveau libre de quitter
le pays malgré les accusations de
torture et de génocide et puis direction
le canada pour la première fois de son
histoire le québec pourrait être reconnu
comme une nation à part entière
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
ap
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent à chaque au point
de bâtiments de salles de sport de place
de la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station bihan ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
[Musique]
si demain d'un conflit ouvert ce produit
entre la chine et les usa
on peut penser il se déroulera dans la
mer de chine du sud
car cette zone est totalement
stratégique pour les deux sens en 2019
la chine a construit en une année temps
de paix plus de bâtiments que les états
unis
en quatre ans de guerre de 1941 à 1945
en affichant ainsi sa souveraineté en
mer de chine du sud
pékin fait prévaloir des droits dits
historiques sur les règles
internationales dont une puissance
dominante constate qu'elle est en train
de se faire dépasser dans une puissance
émergente la tentation normale et de la
détruire au plan politique ou militaire
avant qu'elle n'arrive à ses fins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur arte france si
vous nous rejoignez en espagne brahim
ghali a été entendue ce mardi par la
justice le leader du mouvement
indépendantiste sahraoui atteint ducobu
19 et d'un cancer faisait l'objet de
deux plaintes notamment pour génocides
détentions illégales et torture
mais le juge n'a pas répondu aux
demandes de l'accusation est il à saraf
devant le tribunal une ambiance tendue
durant l'audience le leader sahraoui a
réfuté toutes les accusations
les questions notamment porté sur sa
gestion des camps de tindouf à la
frontière algéro-marocaine
brahim ghali est suspecté dit avoir
ordonné des actes de génocide et de
torture en 2009 contre des sahraouis
il a été démontré lors de sa déclaration
que les actes pour lesquels il a été
inculpé sont absolument est fortement
improbable
ou pour le dire autrement faux le
président ghali a expliqué qu'en tant
que ministre des affaires étrangères
pendant cette période ainsi que ministre
de la défense il n'a participé à aucune
action et n'a eu aucun des comportements
qui lui sont reprochés dans cette
accusation sur cette plainte déposée par
l'association sahraouie pour la défense
des droits de l'homme brahim ghali s'est
soumis aux questions du juge du
procureur et de son avocat mais il a
refusé comme la loi espagnole y autorise
de répondre aux questions des avocats de
l'accusation
même scénario pour la deuxième plainte
le leader du front polisario a nié toute
détention arbitraire à l'endroit de
fadel brekka un espagnol d'origine
sahraouie qui l'accusent également de
torture lors d'un séjour dans la ville
algérienne de tindouf en avril 2019
ce n'est pas vrai
les tortures sont plus que confirmé il y
a des milliers de témoins mais bien sûr
nous n'avons pas été soumis à la
contradiction parce qu'il n'a pas
répondu
alors évidemment ce que l'on peut tirer
de ces échanges c'est une conclusion un
peu personnel
il n'y a pas de politique dans cette
affaire il n'y en a pas les avocats de
la partie civile avait réclamé
l'emprisonnement provisoire de brahim
ghali ainsi que la confiscation de son
passeport
le juge a estimé qu'aucune preuve ne
pouvait justifier un placement en
détention ou une limitation de mouvement
la seule contrainte imposée par le
magistrat espagnol à brahim ghali et de
fournir une adresse et un numéro de
téléphone où il pourra être contacté et
bachir ou bi bouchraya mans du
secrétariat national du front polisario
en charge de l'europe et de l'union
européenne se félicite de cette décision
rendue
notre président a accepté volontairement
de coopérer avec la justice et que il a
démontré au juge que les deux plaintes
ils n'ont aucun aucun fondement et a
seulement le mobile politique daniel
tous acquis à qui avait comme objectif
de d'entacher l'image de la lutte du
peuple du sahara occidental à travers
l'image de son audition leader ça c'est
une chose
et l'autre chose ce que le juge a a
décidé de ne pas donner suite aux
demandes et la partie de l'optimisation
l'accusé de l'accusation en terme des
mesures préventives puisqu'il n'a vu
aucun lien ce lieu entre le planter le
président sahraoui
quand ils le vivent eux ni avec eelv
unis à cause de son hospitalisation et
l'état de santé
il faut aller les causes de sa présence
il le sol espagnol ne sont plus là bien
sûr il reviendra chez lui il ne
reprendra ses fonctions par le président
de la rasd il n'y a pas de doute là
dessus
et pour en parler nous sommes avec kader
abderrahim directeur de recherche à
l'institut de prospective et de sécurité
en europe auteur de géopolitique de
l'âge
géopolitique du maroc aux éditions
bibliomonde bonsoir kader ferhaoui merci
d'être avec nous le chef du polisario
laissé libre donc à l'issue de son
audition par le juge espagnol il peut
donc quitter l'espagne on rappelle quand
même qu'il était accusé de tortures et
de génocide
c'est une décision qui vous a surpris
c'est difficile de dire ce que l'on
pense parce que c'est quand même un
dossier extrêmement compliqué sur le
plan diplomatique à gérer pour l'espagne
et elle a vu le faire en prenant son
temps
et quoi que quelle que soit la décision
qu'ils auraient pu être prises elle
aurait forcément mécontenter l'une des
deux parties
donc aujourd'hui bay rallye et est libre
de rentrer chez lui comme le vient de le
dire son représentant pour l'europe
pour autant la question n'est pas réglée
donc parce que la menace qui pèse sur
lui sur les épaules pour être tout à
fait se reproduire à l'occasion d'un
autre voyage d'un prochain voyage en
europe
donc la question n'est pas réglée et
peut-être qu'il faudrait enfin revenir
au fond de ce dossier et tenter de
parvenir un véritable compromis
politique qui éviterait d'en poser des
relations telles que celles qui se
développent depuis quelques semaines
notamment entre le maroc et l'espagne
justement kader abderrahim cette
décision du juge espagnol quelles
conséquences sur cette crise entre rabat
et madrid et il est probable que le
maroc ne réagissent pas de manière très
positive puisque il l'escomptait
vivement que par ali puisse être sinon
incarcéré au moins qu'il y ait
l'ouverture d'un procès puisqu'il ya une
plainte est déposée par un citoyen
espagnol d'origine sahraouie
donc il est peu probable évidemment que
le maroc est content de cette décision
et que sept dossiers soit relancée à une
prochaine occasion
comme je le disais il ya un instant au
cours d'un prochain voyage en europe ou
bien ou bien peut-être que palm rallye
va te faire un peu oublier sur le plan
diplomatique dans les mois qui viennent
clairement on était face à un procès
politique qui d'une certaine manière
était une façon de déplacer le problème
de fond comme vous le disiez oui on est
là dans une situation très très complexe
sur le plan diplomatique à gérer encore
une fois fort pour les espagnols qui ont
des relations privilégiées avec le maroc
qui la pointe sud de l'espagne est la
plus proche des côtes marocaines 1 il ya
moins de 20 de 15 km entre les deux pays
donc c'est dire que les relations sont
pas seulement commercial ou économique
ou diplomatique mais elles sont aussi
humaine et on a eu l'occasion de s'en
rendre compte il ya une quinzaine de
jours à l'occasion de ses commandes ya
tentative de migration d'immigration
clandestine parole sur le sol espagnol
notamment à ceuta dans cette enclave
espagnole sur le sol marocain
donc oui c'est un dossier éminemment
politique
évidemment on va pas se cacher derrière
son petit doigt
les européens ont clairement pris le
parti du maroc parce qu'ils estiment que
les revendications marocaines sur la
souveraineté du sahara sont légitimes et
que aujourd'hui
du reste les marocains ont une belle
victoire diplomatique avec la
reconnaissance de cette souveraineté du
sahara par parler c'est unis par donald
trump un peu avant qu'il ne quitte la
maison blanche c'est une avancée
importante
disons le présent bayonne n'a pas
l'intention de revenir sur cette
décision
maintenant toute la question est de
savoir comment est ce que ce dossier va
être géré est-ce que l'on
sider que la question est tranchée
qu'elle est réglée une fois pour toutes
ou bien est ce que l'on considère que
les résolutions de l'onu ne sont pas
encore parvenus au terme des débats et
qu'elles ne sont pas encore respectée et
que la question de la colonisation de
ces provinces du sahara reste posée et
reste entière et qu'elle ne peut pas
faire l'objet d'un débat à mu
aujourd'hui effectivement rien n'est
réglé ça fait des années que ça dure
pour vous l'observateur la résolution de
ce problème viendra du goûter
franchement j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire et de l'écrire dans dans mon livre
sur le sat sur la géopolitique du maroc
à propos de la question du sahara
la clé est en algérie elle est à alger
alger est aujourd'hui et depuis
quasiment le début de ce conflit en 1975
un peu après que ce soit la libye de
mouammar kadhafi l'algérie est le
soutien le plus important du front
polisario sur le plan logistique et sur
le plan demi sur le plan diplomatique
donc cela passera nécessairement par un
dialogue et un compromis politique avec
l'algérie peut-être pas directement sur
cette question du sahara
parce qu'il ya d'autres dossiers qui
empoisonnent les relations entre les
deux voisins maghrébins et que peut-être
il faudrait utiliser ou adopter la
stratégie palestinienne
lorsqu'ils ont commencé à négocier avec
israël en 1992 93
les accords d'oslo c'est à dire que les
palestiniens ont considéré que la
question de jérusalem est extrêmement
complexe
là encore sur un plan juridique et
politique mais peut-être davantage
encore sur le plan symbolique
ici on est dans une situation analogue
comparaison n'est pas raison
évidemment le sahara il faut bien le
comprendre l avoir présent à l'esprit et
pour les marocains et pour la monarchie
une question d'identité est un enjeu de
politique intérieure
donc la monarchie ne renoncera pas à ses
revendications et à sa souveraineté sur
ces territoires
donc aujourd'hui pour pouvoir avancer
sur ce dossier
il faut avancer sur beaucoup d'autres et
évidemment avec l'algérie je rappelle
que cela fait presqu'un demi siècle
ce conflit a commencé c'était en
novembre 75 et que là la frontière entre
l'algérie et le maroc est fermée depuis
donc il y a d'énormément de dossiers et
de et d'antagonisme entre les deux pays
et escalade c'est un étang diplomatique
qui devient inquiétante et je crois
qu'il faut entrer aujourd'hui dans le
dialogue politique de manière à amorcer
une désescalade
c'est l'intérêt de l'ensemble de la
région parce qu'elle est une
recompositions géopolitiques en cours il
ya des menaces auxquelles les deux pays
peuvent faire passe en seul ensemble
pardon alors que seuls c'est beaucoup
plus difficile
merci beaucoup kader abderrahim
directeur de recherche ellipses et
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france le québec est-il à l'aube d'une
nouvelle ère constitutionnelle pour la
première fois de son histoire la
province pourrait être reconnu comme une
nation à part entière avec pour langue
officielle et commune le français
une inspiration de longue date qui avait
jusqu'à présent a subi le refus
catégorique du pouvoir fédéral d'ottawa
il y a quelques semaines pourtant justin
trudeau le premier ministre canadien a
créé la surprise en approuvant le projet
les explications en images
[Musique]
m
et
oh
effectivement le québec a le droit de
modifier une partie de la constitution
pour souligner des constats que nous
avons déjà fait au niveau du
gouvernement fédéral
c'est à dire que le québec consiste en
une nation que c'est une province où la
langue officielle est le français
[Musique]
on pourra en parler nous sommes avec
jérôme blanchet gravel correspondant de
spoutnik au canada bonsoir jérôme
blanchet gravel merci d'être avec nous
le québec une nation à part entière
c'est une inspiration pour les canadiens
qui qui date à vacquiers qui est de
longue date par don et qui trouve enfin
un écho au sein des autorités
canadiennes c'est un véritable espoir
d'une certaine façon le québec peut-être
qui peut-être qu'on va entrer dans une
nouvelle ère constitutionnelle mais dans
une nouvelle ère politique j'en doute
beaucoup
donc c'est un geste d'affirmation
nationale qui était pourtant le donc le
projet de loi 96 qui vise à connaître
afin de connaître la nation québécoise à
l'intérieur de la constitution
canadienne
donc ça fait beau dit comme ça mais la
vérité c'est qu'on est quand même devant
une mesure cosmétique au juridique
encore une fois les c'est à dire qu'on
est quand même devant un gouvernement le
gouverneur legault est un gouvernement
très modérée gouvernement d'équilibrer
c'est une coalition
donc c'est un geste d'affirmation
nationale met ce qu'il veut avoir des
vraiment des impacts concrets en ce qui
concerne l'autonomie du québec
à l'intérieur la fédération vraiment ça
reste à voir et ça restera dans le
symbole pour vous ben c'est sûr que vous
savez les symboles sont très importants
important politique donc la vie
politique est marquée par des par des
gestes symboliques et cetera
mais la vérité si vous voulez mon avis
est que tant et aussi longtemps que le
québec décidera de rester à l'intérieur
de la fédération et bien son espace
autonomie va toujours rester très limité
donc c'est un peu aussi les reproches
qu'on fait au gouvernement d'un côté le
gouvernement satisfait les demandes des
nationalistes québécois qui depuis
effectivement des années depuis le début
réclament davantage
loi pour protéger la culture et
l'identité québécoise
et de l'autre côté le gouvernement
satisfait aussi les anglophones du
québec qui
qui voit que le gouvernement finalement
ne va pas non plus à adopter des lois
trop contraignantes qui vont limiter
l'espace de liberté des anglophones à
l'intérieur du québec donc quand je vous
dis c'est au gouvernement d'équilibriste
on est vraiment dans la modération là
aujourd'hui qui l'emportent finalement
les québécois qui sont attachés à la
culture française ou plutôt les
anglophones qui tient la corde
ces mots sim aussi mais ce qui ce qui ce
qui est comique comme d'habitude par
exemple si la réaction du canada anglais
donc pas des anglophones du québec mais
des anglophones du canada du reste du of
canada comme on les appelle donc comme
d'habitude c'est vu comme un coup de
force par exemple il faut dire que c'est
vu comme un geste d'affirmation
inacceptable la part des anglophones qui
dont certains ont quand même
entretiennent encore aujourd'hui ne font
une sorte de mépris le colonial envers
les québécois vu un peu comme les les
indigènes la fédération donc j'ai quand
même un vieux pont de mépris qui ressort
à l'endroit des canadiens d'origine
française
donc ça c'est assez comique d'observer
ça mais vous savez c'est pas très
surprenant là à chaque fois que le
québec pose un geste d'affirmation
nationale le canada anglais bon on est
un petit peu indigne et donc de ce point
de vue là peut-être que je donnerais
donnerait la victoire aux nationalistes
québécois
ceci dit vous savez aussi que pour
préserver une culture et une langue ça
prend beaucoup plus que des lois en fait
le problème au québec c'est con sur
valorise l'anglais qui est vu comme une
langue est la langue du commerce à
l'angle de la réussite et cetera du
succès donc le problème c'est pas eu ce
n'est pas seulement un problème
juridique c'est un problème culturel et
et c'est ça il faut plus que des lois et
des règlements au final pour préserver
la culture québécoise
alors quand même ça ce n'est pas qu'un
symbole la langue française comme langue
officielle ça ça changerait quelque
chose ça
encore une fois je vous dirais que oui
et oui et non oui on peut les deux ans
on peut inclure les amendements
constitutionnels le québec peut modifier
la partie de la constitution qui le
concerne seulement lui mais ça va pas
vraiment changé la l'aménagement
constitutionnel général le canada vont
rester le canada donc une langue un pays
qui wii fait la promotion d'une un
bilinguisme d'une manière assez
vertueuse un peu superficiel mais la
vérité c'est que l'anglais continue de
progresser au québec à montréal
ecce terra le québec reste une une
enclave en amérique du nord donc il y
avait près 350 millions d'anglophones
qui autour du québec là avec le canada
et les états unis donc vous comprenez
que si on est comme un peu assiégée
donc moi j'hésite à parler de victoire
évidemment c'est un pas dans la bonne
direction on peut dire mais la vérité
c'est que ce serait pas suffisant on
peut clairement aujourd'hui parler de
soutien de de justin trudeau on rappelle
quand même qu'il ya des élections qui
qui s'approche jusqu'où ira-t-il dans ce
dans ce soutien justement on est surpris
c'est quand même un geste d'ouverture de
la part de justin trudeau mais c'est
aussi un calcul électoral parce que vous
savez les élections qui approchent et au
québec le québec dispose quand même de
23% des tous les sièges à la chambre des
communes donc justin trudeau a besoin de
l'appui des québécois aux prochaines
élections pour être réélu donc il ne
peut pas se permettre de faire fi de
cette revendication pour le moins
légitime de la nation québécoise dont
que justin trudeau est ce que c'est un
pur calcul électoral où tout d'un coup
il s'est développé une sorte de
sympathie envers le français
on peut lui donner le bénéfice du doute
à peut-être que je sais trudeau a tout
d'un coup se réveille il est pense que
le français est aussi plus important
qu'avant pour lui mais c'est sûr qu'on
peut pas faire fi des des intérêts
électoraux très très clairs et merci
jérôme à blanchet gravel d'avoir été
avec nos correspondants technique au
canada et la découverte des restes de
215 enfants au cno
autochtones sur le site d'un ancien
pensionnat en colombie britannique
continue de bouleverser le canada le
pays a mis ses drapeaux officiels en
berne en signe de deuil tandis que des
cérémonies en mémoire des jeunes
victimes ont eu lieu dans plusieurs
régions
[Musique]
partout dans le pays l'émotion est
palpable
les canadiens ont tenu à se mobiliser
pour montrer leur soutien
les restes humains ont été repérés par
un expert et des d'un géoradar sur le
site d'un ancien pensionnat gérées par
l'église catholique est fermée en 1969
ce type d'établissement créée à la fin
du 19e siècle et dont l'existence a
perduré jusque dans les années 1990
avait pour but de retirer les enfants
autochtones de leur communauté pour les
assimiler deux forces à la culture
dominante
[Musique]
je ne peux même pas imaginer ce que les
parents les mères vivent savoir qu'ils
ont perdu des proches et très difficile
nous devons tous prendre le temps
d'assimiler ce qu'on nous a dit ce que
nous avons vu nous devons digérer
nous avons le coeur lourd
nous allons ensemble trouver les
ressources mais cette perte est
absolument impensable
le premier ministre justin trudeau a lui
reconnu l'échec épouvantable d'ottawa
dans ses relations avec les communautés
autochtones
le chef du gouvernement qui a fait de la
réconciliation l'une de ses priorités
depuis son arrivée au pouvoir en 2015 a
exprimé sa tristesse pour honorer les
215 enfants qui ont perdu la vie à
l'ancien pensionnat de kamloops et les
enfants autochtones qui ne sont jamais
rentrés à la maison les survivants et
leurs familles
j'ai demandé la mise en berne des
drapeaux de la tour de la paix et des
immeubles fédéraux
il s'est aussi dit favorable à un débat
d'urgence à la chambre des communes
répondant à l'appel lancé lors d'un
point presse par jacques meeting le chef
du nouveau parti démocrate au bord des
larmes
215 enfants autochtones ont été
retrouvés dans une fosse commune non
marquées
chaque fois que nous pensons à des
fosses communes ont marqué nous pensons
un pays lointain au moins génocide a eu
lieu ce n'est pas un pays lointain
c'est ici au canada justin trudeau a
depuis annoncé que le gouvernement
allait financer la recherche et
l'exhumation de reste sur d'autres sites
de pensionnat anciens selon les
estimations quelque cent cinquante mille
enfants amérindiens métis et inuits ont
été incorporés de force dans 139
pensionnat travers le pays en 2015
une commission nationale d'enquêté a
qualifié ce système de génocide culturel
et c'est la fin de cette émission
prochain point complet sur l'actualité
dans quelques minutes avec david khalifa
quant à moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain soir à 20h excellente
fin de soirée at-on sur rt france
de la mairie
[Musique]
en avril